-The President of
the United States threatened
to unleash the military
on American citizens
protesting the brutal
police murder of George Floyd.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump's speech last night
was one of the most
menacing moments
in his 3 1/2 years as
president,
and that's saying a lot,
given that he is always
menacing.
Remember during the debates
when he stalked Hillary Clinton
like a "Naked and Afraid"
contestant
trying to sneak up on a bird?
I mean, half the time it looks
like he's on a chain
in the front yard
scaring away a mailman.
He only has two modes --
menacing sociopath,
or limp French fry
that's been sitting
in the bottom of the bag
soaking up all the oil.
And last night he cycled
through both of them.
in turns threatening to unleash
the military
on American citizens
within our borders,
and at other times, listlessly
reading on of a teleprompter
like he just finished
a Thanksgiving meal
of Turkey with
Sudafed stuffing.
-America needs creation,
not destruction.
Cooperation, not contempt.
Security, not anarchy.
Healing, not hatred.
Justice, not chaos.
-[ As Trump ]
"Coke, not Pepsi.
McDonald's, not Wendy's.
Pizza Hut, not Domino's.
But if there's no Pizza Hut,
Domino's is fine."
He's reading a speech in the
middle of a national crisis
like a 13-year-old reading from
the Torah at a bar mitzvah.
Can someone at least show him
these speeches
before he reads it cold
off a teleprompter,
like he's getting his vision
tested at the DMV?
"E, S, M, Q.
Oh, we love Q.
Oh, we love the Q,
don't we, folks?
So many great words use the Q.
Quiznos.
Hydroxychloroquine.
Quick!"
But when he wasn't mindlessly
reading off empty platitudes,
he was adopting a much darker
and more sinister tone,
threatening to sic the
military on American citizens
and violently crack down on
nationwide protests
over the murder of yet another
unarmed black man
at the hands of police.
-Today I have strongly
recommended to every governor
to deploy the National Guard
in sufficient numbers
that we dominate the streets.
Mayors and governors must
establish an overwhelming
law enforcement presence until
the violence has been quelled.
If a city or state refuses
to take the actions
that are necessary to defend
the life and property
of their residents,
then I will deploy
the United States military
and quickly solve
the problem for them.
-I know our brains have
all melted
from the constant
flagrant lawlessness
and overall weirdness of this
administration,
and nothing feels real
anymore
and we're all just programmed
to move on to the next thing
because Trump will inevitably do
something bizarre the next day,
like throw a tantrum
in the Rose Garden
or rub up against the flag like
a horny 16-year-old at prom.
But this is a horrifying
moment.
You know how over 3 1/2 years
everyone was warning
about the inevitable
worst-case scenario
where our democracy crumbles
and our country descends
into authoritarianism?
That worst-case scenario is
here, it's happening.
You're not going to get an
invitation in the mail
asking you to RSVP to the
"Democracy is Over" party.
There's no on/off switch.
Democracy, it turns out,
is on a dimmer.
This is what it looks like.
In fact, last night police
violently attacked
peaceful protesters
lawfully exercising
their First Amendment rights
just so Trump could walk over
to a church for a photo op.
-Within the last 15 minutes,
mounted police have been coming
down the street, you're going to
see them in the frame now,
using flash bangs
in front of them,
and mounted police
to clear what has been
an entirely peaceful protest.
Not 98%...
[ Flash bangs bursting ]
...not 99%, but 100%
peaceful protest here today.
People throwing -- there was
no throwing of water bottles,
there was no throwing
of objects.
But a short time ago,
mounted police officers
have been clearing the street.
Tony, if you can pan
to the right,
I want to show the
military police --
-We live in
a Third-World country!
-I want to show
the military police
on the side of the street.
Over the last half hour,
we've had military police,
we've had Secret Service
officers,
we've had park police,
and now we've
had National Guardsmen.
You can see these officers
aiming at the protesters
who are here in the park.
-Military police
in your country
attacked peaceful protesters,
not looters,
to stop them from exercising
their First Amendment rights.
Trump couldn't have done more
damage to the Constitution
last night if he'd pulled
a Sinead O'Connor
and ripped it up
on live television
and then ate the pieces.
This moment probably seemed
far off
when the extent of Trump's
lawlessness was just
paying off porn stars
or colluding with Russia
or sending the Soviet
Super Mario Brothers over here
to get Ukraine to interfere
in our election.
But he got away
with all of that.
He got away with all of that,
and now the moment has arrived.
Because the only lesson Trump
has learned through all of this
is he can get away with
whatever he wants.
The president used police to
violently attack
a peaceful protest just so he
could walk over to a church
where even the clergy
fiercely condemned him.
And hold up a Bible in front of
the cameras like a fourth grader
who forgot about show-and-tell
until the last minute.
You can tell he's a man of faith
from the way he holds the Bible
like he's selling it on QVC.
It wasn't even his,
and he didn't seem to know
where it came from.
A reporter asked him about it
and this was his answer.
-Is that your Bible?
-It's a Bible.
-Why so vague?
Did you steal from it a hotel?
He holds it like he's never held
a Bible before in his life.
He probably doesn't know
how to read it either.
Based on his grasp of
Christianity,
he probably reads it upside down
and backwards.
"Lot's wife
was a pillar of salt,
but then she looked back at
Sodom, cured just like that."
Clergy at the church denounced
Trump's actions toward
protesters and his use of
the church for a photo op.
And in case you think maybe
the people around Trump
will just ignore his lawless
authoritarianism,
the Chairman of the Joint
Chiefs, a four-star general,
was patrolling the streets
of D.C. last night.
The Defense Secretary told
governors responding to protests
that they, quote, "Need to
dominate the battle space."
A U.S. Senator was calling on
the president to send in
lethal military units to subdue
protesters.
And military helicopters also
performed a show of force
maneuver that is often used in
combat zones
to scare away insurgents.
They're treating protesters
like insurgents.
Honestly, how long until Trump
coasts down Pennsylvania Avenue
on top of a tank in a mouse suit
and a bunch of Gaddafi scarves?
What we're seeing now is part
the result of a cult-like
political ideology
that venerates violence
and blithely elevated
an authoritarian strongman
who openly fantasizes
about armed conflict.
For as long as he's been
a public figure,
Trump has also been
an armchair thug
who glorifies violence.
For example, and this is
a true story,
Trump used to fast-forward
through
[bleep] Jean-Claude Van Damme
movies so he could just watch
the violent parts
without any plot.
A "New Yorker" writer who
traveled with Trump on his plane
in the '90s wrote, "that he
brought along 'Michael,'
a recent release, but 20 minutes
after popping it into the VCR,
he got bored and switched
to an old favorite,
a Jean-Claude Van Damme slugfest
called 'Bloodsport'
which he pronounced an
incredible, fantastic movie
by assigning to his son the task
of fast-forwarding through
all the plot exposition,
Trump's goal being
'to get this two-hour movie
down to 45 minutes.'
He eliminated any lulls between
the nose-hammering,
kidney-tenderizing,
and shin-whacking."
Trump brought along a VCR copy
of the 1996 movie "Michael"
starring John Travolta
as an archangel
whose main mission on Earth
is to get the main characters
to fall in love,
and he bailed after 20 minutes.
"He's an angel? I thought this
was about a man pigeon.
The cover looks like
a man pigeon.
Oh, I mean, just imagine the
damage a man pigeon would do."
Also, what part of "Bloodsport"
could even be fast-forwarding
through anyway?
Was there a subplot in
"Bloodsport" I'm not remembering
where Van Damme gives up
ninjitsu to focus
on his love of pottery making?
That's why he sits around
barfing up psychotic tweets
where he threatens protesters
with vicious dogs
and ominous weapons.
Remember, this is a guy who also
emulates dictators,
who praised China for the
Tiananmen Square massacre,
and who has repeatedly claimed
he's the most militaristic
person who's ever existed,
whatever the hell that's
supposed to mean.
-I am the most militaristic
person.
I would say I am the most
militaristic person
on that stage.
I am the most
militaristic person
you've ever had on your show,
believe me, okay?
I'm the most militaristic
person ever.
I am the most military-based
and the most militaristic
person on your show.
-All right, first of all,
it's just, you know,
an insane thing
to brag about.
Even actual military people
don't call themselves
militaristic.
It's their job, not their
entire personality.
Chefs don't describe themselves
as being very knife-oriented.
Second, you're not.
You just aren't.
You were never in the military,
you dodged the draft,
and you can't even
stand upright.
You love the military the way
you love the Constitution
and the Bible --
only when it serves you,
and that is not love.
Which you would know if you
[bleep] finished "Michael."
He had a message for you!
And now we're seeing
what happens
when a rotten-brained Boomer
who glorifies violence
is in charge of the most
powerful military in the world.
Yesterday, he shout at governors
on a phone call that they needed
to dominate protesters
with mass arrests.
-You have to dominate.
If you don't dominate,
you're wasting your time.
They're going to run over you,
you're going to look like
a bunch of jerks.
You have to dominate.
And you have to arrest people,
and you have to try people.
And they have to go to jail
for long periods of time.
You're making a mistake because
you're making yourself
look like -- look like fools.
-First of all, there's
no deader giveaway
that you're the villain
than using the word "fools."
You never hear someone say,
"Make sure those refugees get
something warm to eat,
you fools!"
We can't just wait
until November
and hope to vote Trump out.
We need to stand up to him now
to stop the country's
descent into authoritarianism
before it's too late.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
New York City is in crisis,
and City Harvest
has been stepping up
to rescue and deliver
more food to meet the increased
need in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit
the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.